[Music]
[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
[Music]
good evening i'm pierce morgan
uncensored a busy show tonight but we
start with some big breaking news
unfortunately more concerns about the
health of her majesty the queen just
been announced she'll miss the state
opening of the british parliament
tomorrow and the reading of the queen's
speech that formally sets out the
government's plans for the year ahead
the palace says she can't attend due to
episodic mobility problems incredibly
the last time she missed this ceremony
was in 1963 she hasn't missed it in my
lifetime and she's only ever missed it
twice in her entire seventy year reign
both times due to pregnancy we know the
queen struggled increasingly with her
health including about a covenant in
february and i'm sure i speak for all of
us when i say i sincerely wish the very
speediest of recoveries particularly
with the platinum jubilee celebrations
coming up fast we're bringing the ladies
on this breaking news throughout the
show but now my brain dump
well it's apparently victory day in
russia and vladimir putin's been flexing
his supposed military muscle in a north
korea-style parade that will make even
kim jong-un look bashful but the only
victory that putin's marking this year
is becoming the world's biggest loser he
lost the first major battle in ukraine
on the capital kiev he lost as many as
25 000 troops and 38 colonels on the
battlefield he's lost the global safe
havens for the blood-soaked oil billions
of him and his oligarch cronies he's
also turned russia into the most hated
country on earth so for him to stand
there celebrating victory is a
disingenuous farce but the most savage
irony of pewter's victory day is it in
fact marks russia's triumph over nazi
germany the soviet union lost more men
to fighting fascism in world war ii than
any other country 27 million soviets
died for the cause they fought so their
grandchildren could live in peace
but instead putin's chosen war and who
are the nazis today
putin's genocidal rampage has left sways
of ukraine a once flourishing european
sovereign democracy looking more like
london and the blitz smoke choking the
skylines families huddling for refuge in
metro stations homes blasted into
charred remains
and like hitler putin's a delusional
dictator who thinks he's fine to invade
neighbouring countries murdered
journalists ruled by spreading lies and
propaganda even has his own sick
swastika
he's not saving ukrainians from the new
nazis as he so outrageously claims putin
is the 21st century hitler and his bug
thirsty forces are the real new nazis
he's right to say though that ukraine
needs denotifying it does from him
well for all their spin and bluster
local elections have left both of
britain's big party leaders with a big
black eye and a bloody nose and frankly
they deserve it leadership in uk
politics is in a very sorry state
boris johnson's tories lost 487 seats
and 12 councils but despite that
disastrous shellacking party insiders
say boris is buoyant and remains an
asset really that's the kind of thing
that putin's few remaining colonels are
probably saying about their beleaguered
boss
meanwhile opposition leader uh sakir
stama who should have been celebrating
winning 108 new seats for this labour
party is instead been tied up in an
increasingly tight knot of his own
making over breaking lockdown rules
after months of taking the moral high
ground against boris johnson for his
illicit downing straight parties today
starmah dramatically upped the ante by
announcing that he will resign if police
find him over the apparently illicit
beer and curry soiree that he shared
with his campaign staff it's an
amazingly high stakes gamble and of
course would put johnson under huge
pressure to do the same if he does have
to quit
but i suspect hypocrisy and lying might
finish them both off whatever happens
boris broke the rules he set for the
rest of us and then repeatedly lied
about it stalmer said that boris must
resign when police investigated now the
same things happened to him but he
hasn't resigned he just committed to
resign if he gets fined
and as the two of them squabble over
this kind of nonsense and fight for
their political lives the united kingdom
is now facing the very real prospect of
being slowly but surely broken up in a
shock development in northern ireland
nationalist party shin fame which once a
united ireland won the biggest number of
seats for the first time and i fear that
may be the catalyst for the slow
breakdown of the entire united kingdom
coming at the time when the scottish
national party in scotland is also
growing in strength
the seeds in ireland were sown when
brexit when britain signed a brexit deal
that built a trade barrier down the
irish sea and marked off northern
ireland from the rest of the uk having
repeatedly assured us that wouldn't
happen would be totally unacceptable it
was a fudge then and a betrayal and it
was never going to stick and
nationalists have now moved to exploit
that vacuum if the uk is going to stay
together and i hope it does it needs
strong leaders in westminster who earn
the public's trust instead we can't
trust the current crop to run a wealth
stool
if you asked me to name one of the most
enduring loves of my life other than
arsenal football club it would be the
humble london black cat
a purring sleek glossy emblem of britain
always there when you need it safe
secure symbolic sexy
as iconic to the capital city as red
buses bowler hats
but it's in a different league to those
cheap inferior postures like uber
well of course if the busy bodies get
their way and they're trying now this
might be the end of the road for the
black cabs as we know it now i happen to
think the black cabs are not just far
superior to the at brothers they're in a
different class there's no flapping
around on the street trying to find your
driver for half an hour before he
cancels on you no secret spiteful little
rating system who wants to be rated by a
cab driver no following the sat nav down
blind alleys the black tabs show up you
tell the cabbie where you want to go and
he or she will take you there on the
fastest route possible and they don't
need any fancy map to do it the reason
they're able to do it so efficiently is
because of the knowledge
now for the uninitiated the knowledge is
the staggeringly difficult examination
all london black cab drivers have to
pass to qualify it dates back 170 years
it takes about four years to complete
and it requires personal knowledge of 25
000 roads and 20 000 landmarks black cab
drivers don't need satellites because
they've got the knowledge and in
exchange for that knowledge they get
special privileges like being able to
use bus lanes and pick customers up at
the roadside they're not just national
treasures they're global treasures
without any doubt the finest and best
qualified cab drivers on the entire
planet
but now the busy bodies i mentioned
earlier at an influential think tank say
the knowledge and all of those perks
should be scrapped
they say the revolution in consumer
choice means that app-based services
should get all the same entitlements to
bring taxis into the modern age without
any need for the knowledge
this is nonsense shameful nonsense it
must be thwarted the knowledge is what
makes our cab drivers the best in the
world black cab drivers should be deemed
an official endangered species and
protected accordingly the campaign to
save the black cab
starts here
what do black cab drivers actually do
they drive cabs right this is a baker
bakes and a funeral director directs
funerals
so what about actor
when they act right it's literally that
simple
only in these woke ravaged days it's
obviously not allowed to be that simple
the outgoing boss of the royal
shakespeare company says only disabled
people should be able to play richard
iii because the king was disabled this
isn't the first time we've heard this
virtue signaling claptrap brian cranston
was flamed for playing a
wheelchair-bound guy in the upside eddie
redmayne got hammered for playing
disabled astro genius stephen hawking
and then pressured into a groveling
apology when he played a trans character
in the danish girl scalia hansen was
slammed the starring in a movie based on
a japanese manga comic because she's not
japanese which is not a cartoon either
and the same people enraged by these
supposedly inauthentic portrayals have
no problem seeing black actors playing
leading roles in period dramas even if
that is historically wrong and they
shouldn't have a problem with it because
they're actors who are acting that's the
whole point of acting if the wokies get
their way the next person to play hitler
in a movie will have to be a genocidal
nazi and that means only vladimir putin
might qualify last time i checked as his
performance as a global peacemaker shows
his thespian skills leave a lot to be
desired
but i'm sure there's one thing we can
all agree on and it's this this
is not acting
so i'm here to rate you on your recent
visit to aotearoa in new zealand in 2018
okay you'll be moderately happy to know
that you scored three stars three stars
out of what
100 100 no out of five okay very funny
yeah that's privately previously shy
prince harry uh on tv again making his
acting debut in a ridiculous new zealand
advert for his eco travel non-profit
harry clearly is not just a terrible
actor he's also a terrible hypocrite a
guy who constantly preaches about the
environment but uses private jets like
iu's black cats this is like adele
lecturing us about how not to be a diva
the local election result in northern
ireland sent shockwaves through british
politics voters handed republican party
champaign a historic victory and now for
the first time northern ireland has a
nationalist first minister a first
minister who wants a united ireland that
that means a disunited uk
it's an impossible problem for the uk
government and the nationalists have
seized on him
well i'm joined now by douglas murray
he's written extensively on irish
nationalism so douglas i was gonna uh
and i will get to this talk to you about
the campaign to cancel winston churchill
which you've written brilliantly about
in your superb new book we will get to
that but a lot of breaking news in the
last 24 hours i want to i want to sort
of
bring together with you if i may because
it's all sort of constitutional we have
what's happened in northern ireland with
shin fame becoming the dominant party we
also have the queen cancelling the state
opening of parliament indicating that
she is in a very poor way in terms of
her health
that raises specter of what happens
after the queen what happens to the
monarchy what happens to the united
kingdom with what's happening in ireland
and indeed in scotland what's your take
on all this and you know if you're going
to look forward to say 10 years time
will there be a monarchy will there be a
united kingdom
uh there'll be a monarchy um i would
worry about the united kingdom in these
uh circumstances as you say piers i mean
the the gains shin fein made uh in the
local elections historic gains uh should
be troubling to anyone who is like me a
unionist um shin fein of course is an
irish nationalist party and is as well
in my own view an extremist party and
that isn't uh mere rhetoric you know
mary lou mcdonald the head of shin fein
um has an unbelievable track record i
mean just just that you mentioned nazis
earlier you know there's only one statue
to a nazi in europe and it sits in the
park in dublin uh sean russell an ira
member who died on a german nazi u-boat
in 1940. there's a statute here in
dublin and shin fein always pay their um
their respects there mary lou mcdonald a
couple of years ago was taken there to
pay her respects she was as it were
bloodied by the more the more militant
wings of sinn fein that's totally normal
in shin fein history it's not just that
they were an extremist party in the past
it's that they are in the present it's
not just their irish nationalists that
they are actually extreme irish
nationalists violent irish nationalists
always have been and seem to continue to
be i think it's an incredibly worrying
development as you say alongside the the
uh ongoing success of electorally of the
scots nationalists in in in the north
it's uh it's certainly possible we could
see the breakup for our country it's
it's it's it's something i think
everyone who who recognizes that the
united kingdom has been an enormous
force for good in the world should
really be very worried about we should
be very troubled by that you know the
breaking up into these sort of mini mini
national states within the united
kingdom i think it'll be a disaster yeah
and you'll write one other thing quickly
of course of course her majesty the
queen has presided over this period of
of of peace and and union and i worry
enormously about what comes after as
everyone does yeah but we'll be debating
it later about specifically about the
future of the monarchy but it is
troubling times for people who believe
in united kingdom and great britain and
the monarchy this is a worrying time and
there's no getting away from that i want
to turn to your book uh douglas it's a
terrific book the war on the west
specifically i want to talk about the
way we're treating historic heroes not
just winston churchill who was voted the
greatest britain of all the queen would
run him a close second i think
but also american presidents the
founding fathers abraham lincoln and so
on um what you're seeing is the slow
chipping away
of legacies of towering figures uh who i
believe the totality of their
achievement should outweigh the
negatives which go with any human being
of course talks first of all about
churchill because he's coming under
increasing attack from the woke brigade
you know they portray him as a white
supremacist a racist somebody who did
evil things and shouldn't be considered
great in any shape or form what's your
response to that
yeah they they basically find him guilty
of some victorian attitudes which as you
know if you're born in victorian england
you might well have some victorian
attitude surprise surprise if you're
born in the 19th century it turns out
you don't have all of 2022's views um
but you're right i mean the the
anti-westernists which is what i think
they are not just work works are sort of
a manifestation of it but the people who
just hate the west
hate the western democracies
they keep trying to take down our hero
figures and when i first started
noticing i thought this is very strange
you know normally cultural revolution we
start at the margins and move inwards um
but but they haven't and i think that
this is very telling
they have come for winston churchill and
are defaming his reputation and this
isn't just the fringes this isn't just
some protesters uh graffitiing his
statues you know it's it's it's things
like the bbc who now never run a story
about churchill without running a link
to a page of the 10 worst crimes of
winston churchill
we have we have his own the college
named after him at cambridge running
panels about his alleged racism and much
more and when i noticed this i thought
this is strange and i looked at america
and it's the same thing in america the
same thing of finding people guilty of
being born in the past and having some
attitudes of the past has been used to
justify the removals of statues of the
family the lowest moment for me lincoln
i thought the worst moment for me was
when you had the black lives matter
protests in london and they had to board
up the statues in parliament square of
churchill mandela and gandhi three of
the great figures really of the last 100
years had to be protected from a mob
that may want to deface them and scroll
horrible graffiti on them
nobody passes this test appears that's a
crucial thing nobody passes the test you
know as
i say in the war in the west you know
even if you even if you take some of the
criticisms of churchill and like all
people he's a bit flawed everybody is
but even if you take those criticisms
you know just does just standing alone
against adolf hitler and being more
important than any other individual uh
for seeing nazism beaten back does that
count for nothing yeah you know so what
if you like to drink on the side so so
what have you said some things that we
don't agree with today that's your count
in the plus side same thing with abraham
lincoln does freeing the slaves count
for nothing apparently not now abraham
lincoln in america has the same
treatment and even gandhi who just
mentioned gets the same treatment nobody
is good enough
for these people who believe that
history starts with them and only they
in 2022 know what's right and wrong
these people of course are doing
something very very wicked very quickly
they are they know that if they take out
churchill they will take out britishness
at a very fundamental level they take
out jefferson and lincoln they've taken
out america it's no less than an assault
at the very fundamentals of our identity
and our right to feel pride in our own
history i completely agree and i think
if you can't acknowledge that human
people are flawed and complicated and
have good and bad size to them whoever
they are nobody is completely saintly
you know i've seen people now trying to
rubbish mother teresa it's like really
really you think the totality of mother
teresa's life is that she's an evil
woman and i'm sure the queen will get it
too when she passes on it's like just
give it a rest you know we're allowed to
have the ladies
perfect yeah i mean church the lady
master statue only went up a couple of
years ago exactly and they're already
called for it to come down yeah it's
ridiculous
it's ridiculous douglas it's a great
book the war on the west great to have
you on uh please come back great love
hoping as a guest appreciate it
well i'm sensitive next she doesn't get
more unsensitive than my next guest
scary spice from the spice girls mel b
she'll be here live
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to peace morgan on census
by skill mel b has been a global star
for decades perhaps her biggest honor
yet last week when prince william
presented with an mba at buckingham
palace she dedicated her honor to all
women affected by domestic violence and
i'm delighted to say mel b joins me now
mel how are you
hi
good to see you congratulations thank
you how are you you're looking very
tanned
is that makeup or is that your tam
it's actually just a bit of makeup but
it's fine i'll take the compliment i'll
take the win um well talking a win
congratulations on your mbe what does
that mean to you to get an mba and be at
buckingham palace
i mean it's really surreal to be honest
and i don't take it personally to do
with me
it's for all the women that have been
through similar things to what i've been
through so you know it's just more about
raising awareness but to get an mbe for
it is just
kind of crazy i'm like why didn't spice
girls get an mb but
i mean to do it for the women and to do
it for what i'm doing it for is just
like
quite overwhelming it still hasn't
really sunk in because it was only like
a few days ago and are you are you a
monarchist i mean we've got this late
breaking news tonight that the queen is
going to miss the state opening of
parliament obviously a lot of concern
about our health generally right now as
we head towards the platinum jubilee and
amazing achievement are you a big
believer in the royal family the
monarchy
i mean i'm a massive royalist like me my
mom my sister my dad all about the
royals but you know what i mean the
queen's been through so much you know
she's lost the love of her life she's 96
years old so whatever she wants to do
she can do i mean she's the queen so
it's up to her and i kind of bow down to
that
you got your uh gong from uh prince
william and a little dicky bird tells me
that yeah in your earlier life as a
rampant young spice girl before you
matured into a more sensible one that
you guys used to get helicopters down to
high grove and secretly have peanut
butter sandwich parties with william and
harry is that true
well let me just explain i mean we got
invited to highgrove many times and it
wasn't our helicopter it was their
helicopter they'd hire it for us and
pick us up and then we'd arrive on the
lawn it was quite fancy and well to do
and then there'd all be these posh
sandwiches and we'd be like we don't
really want cucumber and
sandwiches let's go in the kitchen and
make some bagels and some peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches and they loved it i
mean they're really young but it was
really nice to see william again
you know i'm all grown up and i'm
getting my mbe and he literally had such
a long conversation with me i got a bit
embarrassed because you know the whole
protocol is you wait for
william to kind of talk to you before
you speak and then he ends the
conversation but this conversation was
going on and on and on and i was looking
behind me i was like there's so many
people waiting to get there
what was it what was he saying to him
was he asking you if you still eat
peanut butter sandwiches or
no i mean i'd like
half of the conversation i'll never tell
anybody because that's between me and
him but it was really kind of taken
aback how
you know i'm a spice girl but yeah i'm
getting the mbe for
um raising awareness for domestic
violence and women that are in
vulnerable situations he was just asking
me about my book
about you know how i was how long i was
in the abusive relationship while he
really went quite deep and then he said
to me goes so who you here with and
obviously my mom's white with blonde
hair and i went i'm with my mum she's
over there and he was like oh hello and
my mom went bright red and the
conversation still carried on he was so
sweet and so polite and respectful i was
one that was like okay i think we need
to go now
and yeah it went through my curtsy and i
whisked off and i was just
i was just kind of in shock but so happy
and so delightful when you see mel when
you see
right when you you know having having
had these fun times at high grove with
him and harry when they were like
inseparable brothers how do you feel
about the way that their relationship
has fractured so badly at the moment
well i mean that's just what the press
are saying nobody knows really what
happens behind closed doors you know
it's true i mean those brothers it is
unquestionably true so
they are they are probably
i mean they're brothers at the end of
the day i have three daughters and you
know
i'm closer to one child for this closer
to my middle child for that so
you just don't really know what kind of
dynamic happens behind closed doors like
when you saw the whole kind of furore go
down with you know exit when him and
harry and megan left the country and we
we had the first biracial member of the
royal family and everyone was so full of
hope about it all and so positive around
the wedding and then suddenly within 18
months it was all over and she gone you
come from a biracial uh background
yourself what did you make did you feel
sad that it ended so quickly and so
acrimoniously
uh well i don't really take what happens
in the media as the gospel truth you
know i was just happy that
um the monarchy was so accepting of
somebody of black and white descendant
you know because it's so
white and very british which i love the
wilds like i said so it was kind of
a shame that it got presented in the way
that it did but like i keep on saying
nobody knows what happened you know and
if one of my kids wants to go and live
in australia or new zealand or
israel you know i will always be
supportive you know finally well you've
done some great work on that no no
you've just
it's uncensored you can say what the
hell you like on this show the
the uh i know i can and i'm talking to
you remember
the issue of domestic violence you've
written so powerfully about and spoken
so powerfully about now being awarded
for your work in this area
right now there's this grizzly trial
going on about probably one of the worst
toxic marriages i think i've ever
witnessed between johnny depp and amber
we've had two trials now in the middle
of the second one does this kind of
thing actually is it damaging to the
calls that you're trying to advance and
promote
i mean this is such like as
a very sensitive topic for me because
it's so personal
but um
to me this trial is is so this case is
so not entertainment for me
and what i what i worry about is it's
gonna damage
you know future men or women coming
forward and making their own claims or
the justice system having doubt or not
believing because at the end of the day
you know we can't get away from the fact
that two women get killed every week in
this country by their former partner or
their current partner as opposed to 12
men a year so i have to kind of remind
myself that i'm glad that people are
aware of the situation which is an
epidemic of domestic violence and
coercive control and any form of abuse
but i also think
that to look at this case as
entertainment is damaging and that's why
i have not even looked at it at all by
the way i've been in colorado with ruby
wax filming for three weeks which is
another story
which has been amazing so to to land
back in england on
sunday because i now live in leeds with
my mom surrounded by nature um
it was really kind of it really
made me have like a lump in my throat to
think that this is televised because i
know when i went through all my stuff in
the us
i i actually had to like file court
papers to be to have a closed um
courtroom because otherwise tmz we're
going to be allowed in and all these
different outlets and
cameras and filming and all that stuff
and luckily the judge granted me for it
to be a closed court so i do think i
mean i think it's incredibly sad
it's very squalid and it's very sad and
it's like it's like this awful toxic
relationship exploding in everyone's
judging everyone's judging what
everyone's bound to judge
i think it's
yeah we assume a nature is a judge i
don't think you can blame the public or
even the media these two are at each
other's throats and they're doing it in
public everyone's going to have a view
but i agree with you the moment that
crosses into entertainment then i think
it devalues the issue that you've
campaigned so courageously for well i'm
going to leave your entertainment with
your tan
what
what's going to do with my time
are you living in l.a are you living
here now because you've got your new job
i know if you just want to spit it out
that you quite fancy the way i'm looking
at the moment just say it it's fine
just get it off your chest
you've been mentioning my town three
times now i'm doing this you look good
you've got good lighting thank you good
lighting a good little bit of a spritzer
going on you're looking you're looking
hot i miss you
let's have dinner soon we've had a lot
of fun over the years i would love to
catch up with you great to see you we
have you take care mel that was probably
uncensored i like it
bye
unscented i didn't swear
you were about to that's why i've had to
get ready great to talk to you
bye
i love melby uh now at a time when
everyone loves to play the victim and i
think we're seeing a bit of that in the
herb debt court case i want to introduce
you to someone who's overcome so much in
her short little life uh but never
played the victim eight-year-old harmony
rose allen was diagnosed with meningitis
when she was a baby and given a 10
chance of survival which is fought the
odds despite losing all four limbs she's
crossed the finishing line of a half
marathon she's competed in gymnastics
she loves to swim
and she's also won a pride of britain
award and today she achieved something
else which is extraordinary although
most of us would just take it for
granted she managed to brush her own
teeth
giannisi is one of the gutsiest young
people i've ever had the pleasure to get
to know she sent me this lovely message
before we came on air
hi
so great to see you back on the telly
again hopefully i can go to your new
studio soon bye
consider an open invitation young lady
you're always welcome here and thank you
for inspiring us all you know her story
and her attitude reminds me of my
favorite all-time poem by d h lawrence
called self-pity something she has never
ever displayed the poem in its entirety
goes like this i never saw a wild thing
sorry for itself
a small bird will drop frozen dead from
a bow without ever having felt sorry for
itself that is harmony rose and we could
all do with invoking more of her spirit
well i'm saying so next the woman who
nudged insulate britain's eco warriors
with her suv and got banned from driving
i'll bring her face to face with
installate britt
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back to piers morgan on censor
eco activists have become a regular
irritant on uk rose sitting in front of
traffic sometimes gluing themselves to
the tarmac i sympathize with their cause
but not the way they're going about it i
think it's dangerous and just winds
people up rather than bring them to
their calls and side but one such person
who did take them on was sharon speed
who'd just been banned from driving
after she nudged three insulin britain
activists with her car when they blocked
her on the school run here's what
happened
but he's 11 he needs to get to school i
need to get to work
move out of the way
joins me now along with liam norton from
insulate britain good evening to both of
you cherylin um when i watched that
video i just see i see a mum desperate
to get a kid to school on time i've got
a 10 year old who i'd take to school but
i walk at a school you have to drive
your son you now can't do that when you
look back at what happened there
describe your frame of mind about what
you encountered and the way you reacted
do you know what it was a really hard
time personally for me um i know more
people are aware of my bit of my
background now i just found it really
stressful you know it's early in the
morning i'm trying to get my sunschool
get to work i've got personal things
going on as well i'm suffering with
anxiety
and i've got these people in front of me
stopping me from going to where i needed
to go
i just found it really difficult a
difficult it's really hard experience
for me
and when you then got dragged through
the courts you were banned from driving
for a year received a 240 pound fine you
were charged with assault although that
got dropped
i mean could you really believe that you
were suddenly being made to look like
the villain in this story
i mean i've been to court three times
for this
um
i'm still shocked that i'm on the
driving by and i'll be honest i don't
really think that i deserve that i mean
they did say it was going to be careless
driving which meant i got points on my
license and a fan and i was happy you
know to accept that i understand that i
did do wrong you know and i take the
consequences but for someone who has no
previous convictions and you know not
even points my license i just felt like
that was a bit harsh and as a result you
now can't drive for a year you can't
take your son to football training he
trains all over london and essex you
can't help your mother with her shopping
and getting around
um it seems to me that you've ended up
being pretty harshly punished here when
in fact you were being prevented just
from going about your normal day
yeah yeah
all right well let's bring in liam
liam you represent insulate britain
i look at that video and i see a mum who
wants to get a kid to school on time you
want to you know protect the planet and
make it better for her son and at the
same time you want to stop him being
educated so people watch that and they
go why are you doing this why can't you
protest in a different way to literally
lying in front of cars to the point
where a young mum loses it and ends up
with a fine and everything else and not
being able to drive a boy around
yeah i mean i i agree with you it's that
it's it's not a good situation i've
spoke to sherilyn about a month ago
and we had a really good conversation
she's still got misgivings about the
tactics that insulate britain were using
back then but she also said to me that
she didn't realize how bad this climate
crisis was for her 11 year old son and
that's a similar position to me like i'm
an electrician appears right i'm just a
normal bloke in 2018 i see the front
page of the paper and there was a
hundred academics including the
archbishop of canterbury who said that
it was morally justifiable to get
arrested because of how bad this climate
crisis was and they blocked bridges and
commentators like yourself were very
unhappy that people were blocking
bridges but that highlighted to me how
bad this crisis is and i still stand by
the the justification for the fact that
public disruption is necessary because
we're looking at the absolute collapse
of
civilization
i actually have a lot of sympathy with
the calls that you're fighting right i
don't disagree with you about the threat
from climate change or global warming
right but what i disagree with you are
about the tactics because yeah insulate
britain you know you've had a case where
a man was trying to drive his mother to
hospital when she suffered a stroke
you know and
he believes the son that if you'd
actually if he got in the hospital
earlier she would have recovered as a
result she's been left paralyzed you had
insulated britain protest causing an
ambulance to be delayed by nearly an
hour on another occasion with a chest
pain emergency another unnamed paramedic
told the metro newspaper that insulate
britain were causing ambulances to be
called in tailbacks created by the
roadblocking protest when i read stories
like this you know my blood boils i'm
like what what right have you got under
the cause of global warming and climate
change which you want to protect young
people in particular from a future which
we don't know that is going to be safe
for them to do this kind of thing where
you imperil people's lives or to stop a
child having an education or not being
able to get around or an old mum being
able to be driven around shopping i
don't think you have the right to play
god like that with people's lives yeah
and and i don't believe that this is a
cause
no no what we're talking about is a
physical reality yeah but it's also a
cause you're fighting a cause and you're
pro there's the real world protest about
all sorts of things the real world
appears right and we need to understand
that we're living in the real world i
understand that what i don't what i
don't understand liam is why you have to
do the kind of things i've just read out
why you have to make that poor woman not
be able to take her son to school there
are other ways to protest but why is
that poor son in 20 years time gonna
live in a world that's one of
unimaginable horror well we don't know
whether we're gonna be in 20 years we do
and this is we need to start to accept
this horrendous physical reality that
exists piers and we're not discussing it
well enough and sherilyn's son is 11
years old doesn't get to have a say in
his future which at the current
trajectory is going to be one of
animations
i come back to the point i agree with
you about the need to take climate
change seriously what i don't agree with
you is stopping people from getting
emergency medical treatment or stopping
children going to school that to me
seems to be the opposite of what you're
trying to achieve which is a safer
future for people yes so what we're
saying here is why aren't we talking
about the government criminality that's
going on when every
person knows like this is happening now
we've got an absolutely catastrophic
heat wave going on in india and pakistan
at the moment to the point where
glaciers are melting in the himalayas
causing rivers to flood and breaking
into everything my point i don't
disagree with you about the dangers that
are being faced to the world i i would
support you the problem i have with your
tactics is you put me off supporting you
you don't bring me to your protest i
don't think i want to join these guys
they're making a great point i just look
at this poor woman and think why have
you done that to her and her kid i look
at these terrible stories of a woman
left paralyzed because you lot were
lying in front of a car why do that
there are other ways to protest because
you're not listening to what i've just
said you're not emotionally connecting
to the fact that what i've just said to
you is one billion actually you're not
listening to what i'm saying no i am but
what i'm saying was we're in what you're
not hearing is i'm agreeing with your
calls with the campaign
i just don't agree with the tactics i
want you to concede but i don't agree
with government criminality let me
finish i want you to concede that the
tactics you've been using are
self-defeating i think there's a better
more effective way to do it i think you
would if you're honest with yourself say
that actually this doesn't work this
kind of thing it might get you a few
lyrid headlines but i don't see any of
the british public go you know what i'm
watching this video i've got to join
that protest they think the opposite
yeah i think you're a bunch of people
wrecking people's lives and i don't
think that's actually what you want to
achieve well look we're prepared to take
the consequences there's 14 people
currently in prison non-violent ordinary
people that are currently in prison
ordinary people like cherylin speed are
receiving unfair sentences nobody wins
here but what we're saying is for the
government that we've got on all we had
an ordinary like a
no-brainer plan
to insulate britain which has been
proven in an energy crisis now i've got
an energy bill with 550 pound that i'm
really struggling to pay i'm sure cheryl
do you enjoy that you famously walked
off good morning britain and you're in
good company all the best people do yeah
you bought off good morning britain when
they asked you if you insulate your own
home and you said you don't because
you're a hypocrite have you started to
insulating yourself i just said to you
i've got a 550 pound bill that i can't
pay right so just just to be clear
though you still don't insulate your own
home even though your whole campaign
you've got to start doing that so we're
talking about social housing i
understand the poorest in our society
we're saying that it won't happen unless
the poorest in our society can can do
the job and as we all know the poorest
in our society are struggling in poverty
but i believe i would take you more
seriously if you did insulate your own
home so are you you're an electrician
you know how to insulate a home right
but and for the last 18 months i've been
doing a job that doesn't pay well peers
right so i'm not a very well-off guy and
what you're saying is that only people
that can afford ten thousand pounds to
insulate and retrofit a problem i'm not
saying that they're the ones that can
have an opinion on this and where i'm
not saying that i'm just saying i'm
saying it would probably help your cause
if you stop lying down in front of mums
trying to take their kids to school or
people whose mothers are literally
having strokes and getting paralyzed if
you stop doing that and you actually
practice what you preach about things
like insulation people might be more
inclined to follow your campaign which
by the way just to finish on i agree
with we can come together we can come
back let's go there we go let me ask
charlie before we get on with this let
me just start showing before we go
final question
do you have any sympathy with what he's
doing
sharon can you hear me
do you have any sympathy with lee yeah i
can hear you now do you have any
sympathy with liam
symbol of him yeah
look i i just
look i spoke to liam i've said him
before i don't agree with their methods
i think we're stronger together um i
think that communication is key i think
that if we talk to people you know if
they come and speak to come to our
community to speak to us
you know maybe they would get more of us
on their side instead of pissing us off
and holding our cars and stuff i agree
i think we're reaching a little point
potential consensus here all right liam
you're on to the right idea you're
executing it in my view in a
self-harming way but we'll continue the
debate okay i'll promise you that
continue the debate good to talk to you
both thank you very much thank you well
uncensored next to queen's hill health
means she won't attend the state opening
parliament for the first time in 59
years what does that mean for her and
what does it mean for the future of the
monarchy we'll debate that next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
well this is here we celebrate the
queen's 70 years of service to platinum
jubilee but with the news that she's
missing tomorrow opening a parliament
were concerned about her health i hope
as i said at the start of the show that
she makes a big recovery in time for
their celebrations but it does raise the
question of course of life after the
queen and indeed the future of the
monarchy joining me now is the
conservative columnist and daughter of
u.s politician john mccain megan mccain
and here in the studio vanity fair royal
editor katie nicole welcome to both of
you uh katie let me start with you this
is a worrying time i think for anyone
like me you we've been in this country
our entire lives with one monarch and
her health is clearly not good it's not
good how surprised should we be given
that she's 96 we know she's had a spate
of ill health um
i don't think anyone really knows quite
what the matter is i mean we were told
we are told that there are problems with
her mobility okay and it's episodic so i
understand some morning she wakes up and
she's all right other morning she wakes
up and she literally what does that mean
we have to consider life after the queen
at some point we do of course what is
the future of the monarchy as far as
you're concerned well i think we're
going to get a pretty good view of it
tomorrow appears because you're going to
see
prince charles the longest-serving
prince of wales representing the queen
delivering the queen's speech
her throne will be empty
but he will fill that throne one day and
you're going to see him flanked by queen
camilla as we now know she's going to be
his eldest son anna the next prince of
wales so i think this is almost a bit of
a projection into the future i think
it's going to be very healthy let's
bring in megan mccain megan i know
you've been pretty scathing about the
whole idea the concept of a monarchy why
i'm an american you know i celebrate the
fourth of july and um it's sort of a
foreign concept for most americans that
being said as uh cheesy as it may seem
the queen uh the crown the show that was
on netflix was a huge hit here and i
think sort of gave a lot of americans a
better understanding of why she is so
beloved and why as the longest-serving
monarch in your history why she should
be respected and i think it's made of a
lot of amer a lot of americans
very territorial of her as well and she
really has become a cult figure in the
past few years since the popularity of
that show uh unlike anything i'd seen
before i mean in terms of the of the
reality of a monarchy really it's just a
figurehead thing for the country it
brings they pay for themselves they make
more money from tourism than they cost
and in the queen we've had this
remarkable rock of stability for 70
years whereas in america of course you
chop and change presidents and sometimes
you get lucky and sometimes you don't
i mean do you understand why we find it
quite comforting to have this kind of
enduring figurehead
sure i mean you know i think also what
has been interesting is to sort of see
uh the modernizing of the monarchy and
the and again i i don't follow this as
closely as people who live in the uk but
i do know that william and kate had a
rocky tour uh recently where uh you know
the had uh prime minister in jamaica had
many things to say uh about not wanting
to be under the monarchy anymore and i
think it'll be interesting as uh
katie said to see how this modernizes um
i'm really american i'm like hardcore
fourth of july like love my guns
american so i don't think i'm ever gonna
be like you look at me basically and you
see you see
you see king george the third
reincarnated when you look at me and
hear me right let's be honest
[Music]
one of the spanners in the works of
course the duke and duchess of sussex
and the ongoing antics they've been
banned from the balcony quite a big
moment by the queen to do that but they
are coming with their kid to presumably
a netflix crew and so quickly how
damaging or otherwise do you think it is
their ongoing behavior oh it is damaging
to the crown it absolutely is i think
the queen had very little option harry
megan made it clear they wanted to be
over here it is a family event as well
she wants her family around her this is
probably going to be the final hurrah um
but i think you'll find those netflix
crews are kept at some distance i think
the idea that they're going to be
allowed to hijack this in any way the
focus needs to stay on the queen
unfortunately the sussex is as always
provide a detraction and megan funny to
you we've got 30 seconds or so are you a
megan harry fan i've seen you be quite
supportive of them i think you were
supportive of them after i had to leave
my morning show actually
i'm not a fan i was a fan of the
beginning because i thought they were
interesting and sort of you know
modernizing the royal family but they're
way too woke for me and harry came after
the second amendment uh in this country
and i believe the first amendment as
well which is like a huge you know it's
like if i had attacked the queen it's
the equivalent and they're just too woke
for me no okay well we agree on that
megan
we agree on that great you've got a
great book out called bad republican
katie your book harry and megan life
loss of love great debate thank you both
very much indeed tomorrow lennox lewis
the great boxing champion and an
official spokesman for the taliban that
doesn't get you watching nothing will
remember keep it uncensored good night
biggest issue in britain right now
undoubtedly is cost of living it is
energy on all that goes with that
inflation look you know i don't want the
government to do very much step back
from most of our lives but you know
there's a point when you say actually
these guys are getting a grip somewhere
along the line you want
to believe that the system that is meant
to be running things the chancellor the
prime minister who are going to somehow
step in and make life just a little
easier for the average person
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zora silverman the
queen will miss tomorrow's state opening
of parliament for the first time in 59
years buckingham palace confirmed her
majesty will not attend the ceremony in
westminster due to episodic mobility
problems prince charles will read the
queen's speech in her place
zakir starmer has vowed to resign if
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you